i have to tell you i honestly love
hosting uh a late night
talk show i always have and uh i've
always thought it was the job that i was
born to do
but every so often i love to try my hand
at another career
and i don't want to brag but i
personally believe i hit it out of the
park
every time take a look yes this is king
walk
what is it you would like what's that
i don't know do we have do we have rice
i got to go i got a delivery i'm going
to hang up on you and your order's not
being placed
[Applause]
i am the delivery guy
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
you can put it on your cheek yes and
then the forehead
what if i go outside and i peek in
through the window looking like this
charlie is now going to teach me how to
drive
the gravedigger we can shut you down
remotely if we feel you're out of
control or
are doing something we don't like
what happened to me at nbc
trevor just informed me off camera i
thought that i was only announcing here
at the track but that is not the case
this is going out where
well it'll go to the whole of america it
goes to south america
it'll definitely be in england you'll be
in every bedding shop in england
i wasn't told this here we go and it's
pancakes on the griddle as the horses
[Applause]
yes this race is really up the jockeys
bottoms are in the air which is the way
that
horses bottoms high that's the way to go
boys
and here we go it looks like this is a
very exciting race
it's knuckles someone just saw me it's
knucklebuster
it looks like knucklebusters taken in by
your head
oh good golly miss molly pull out the
kitchen
grab the onions and cook yourself
somebody
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so i'm going to narrate from behind
camera
the scenarios okay and then you're going
to
act them okay and action
and then you're driving along and
driving along and all of a sudden these
storm clouds show up
and it looks like rain but it's like
katrina rain
you look nervous when all these storms
are happening yeah
yeah so you said katrina
right you said katrina's coming that's
right
and you don't want me to look nervous
because the real what we're really
selling is not a car we're selling
safety and security i see
okay so no matter what happens yes so
right now i'm driving the ford delusion
i know you're driving and driving you
know bike messenger hits your car
you're in the delusion no wait a minute
wait a minute
wait a minute you're saying i hit a guy
on a bike
but because i'm in such a nice luxury
car
i don't give that's crazy
this car is making me immoral the
clients the clients
do not want us to worry about a human
being
human beings must be eradicated
so we're driving along and driving along
and all of a sudden
this bike messenger hits your car
be at the autopsy this is where people
sit with dolls and eat
do i need to name my doll you absolutely
can name your doll
she is your doll agnes agnes
fights hoffa she was born in germany
she entered the united states illegally
and
her activities are suspicious
see the gluten-free baked chicken
tenders absolutely i don't
want it look you have to try something
you have to eat something
you can't have dessert unless you take
three bites
of the chicken destroy threes
one and two and three up down one
two up down i don't suppose we could use
his body
and then in editing put my head
[Applause]
[Music]
you were still twisting
you
all right the rest of you may remain in
the dance troupe
you're now all uber drivers
[Applause]